[Music]
let's [__] this party in the mouth like
shortcut podium etc right what I'm doing
my time is my business my choice baby
[Music]
sweet birthday baby what was I just
doing what what do you mean I'm out of
here
[__] sweet birthday is in this Christ
that stars are you tell me what's going
on I keep dying and reliving the same
night does it hurt yes you seem fine I'm
not fine I'm questioning my own sanity
we got to take the fire escape I really
I changed my Airbnb saying that what was
wrong with the stairs it's a long story
involving multiple deaths yeah this is
much safer I never lasted this long
those things are Venice I'm having a
very hard
never
you stop acting crazy feeling
should I call my guy at Bellevue is it
the nicest psych ward it's definitely
the closest one I look at you now
they sing down death at every corner
violate the light do you still have that
in you
call me
did you get the nose we're about to die
it doesn't matter I did all the time
[Music]
you